there's a job out there with a great
deal of power pay prestige and
near-perfect job security and there's
only one way to be hired get appointed
to the US Supreme Court if you want to
become a justice on the Supreme Court
the highest federal court in the United
States three things have to happen you
have to be nominated by the President of
the United States your nomination needs
to be approved by the Senate and finally
the president must formally appoint you
to the court because the Constitution
doesn't specify any qualifications in
other words that there's no age
education profession or even native-born
citizenship requirement a president can
nominate any individual to serve so far
six justices have been foreign-born at
least one never graduated from high
school and another was only 32 years old
when he joined the bench most presidents
nominate individuals who broadly share
their ideological view so a president
with a liberal ideology will tend to
appoint liberals to the court of course
a justices leanings are not always so
predictable for example when President
Eisenhower a Republican nominated Earl
Warren for chief justice
Eisenhower expected him to make
conservative decisions instead Warren's
judgments have gone down as some of the
most liberal in the courts history
Eisenhower later remarked on that
appointment as the biggest damn fool
mistake he ever made many other factors
come up for consideration as well
including experience personal loyalties
ethnicity and gender the candidates are
then thoroughly vetted down to their tax
records and payments to domestic help
once the president interviews the
candidate and makes a formal nomination
announcement the Senate leadership
traditionally turns the nomination over
to hearings by the Senate Judiciary
Committee
depending on the contentiousness of the
choice that can stretch over many days
since the Nixon administration these
hearings have averaged 60 days the
nominee is interviewed about their law
record if applicable and where they
stand on key issues
to discern how they might vote and
especially in more recent history the
committee tries to unearth any dark
secrets or past indiscretions the
Judiciary Committee votes to send the
nomination to the full Senate with a
positive or negative recommendation
often reflective of political leanings
or no recommendation at all
most rejections have happened when the
Senate majority has been a different
political party than the president when
the Senate does approve it's by a simple
majority vote with ties broken by the
vice president with the Senate's consent
the president issues are written
appointment allowing the nominee to
complete the final steps to take the
constitutional and judicial oaths in
doing so they solemnly swear to
administer justice without respect to
persons and do equal right to the poor
and the rich and faithfully and
impartially discharge and perform all
the duties incumbent upon a US Supreme
Court justice this job is for life
barring resignation retirement or
removal from the court by impeachment
and of the 112 justices who have held
the position not one has yet been
removed from office as a result of an
impeachment one of their roles is to
protect the fundamental rights of all
Americans even as different parties take
power with the tremendous impact of this
responsibility it's no wonder that a US
Supreme Court justice is expected to be
in the words of Irving R Kaufmann a
paragon of virtue and intellectual Titan
and an administrative Wizard of course
not every member of the court turns out
to be an exemplar of justice each leaves
behind a legacy of decisions and
opinions to be debated and dissected by
the ultimate judges time and history